hi I'm Matthew brainy I'm a screenwriter
I've been doing this for about 10 years
now my current screenplay that I'm
working on I've been doing that for
about three weeks now so i'm very new
into the first draft which is always the
best draft of all of them and always the
most challenging one for any wood either
and finish the reason while writing the
screenplays because i really enjoy film
noir movies i really enjoy one location
films and i really enjoy detective
movies so it's kind of good buying my
love roll those things into one project
and to me as a writer I can't feel like
a master dialogue and storytelling until
I've actually written an entire feature
set in one area with very little
characters I have not quit on the script
and I will not quit on the script
because a lesson I learned a long time
ago is every writer writes themselves at
some point and writing any screenplay
and every screenplay they write
themselves in their corner and the
problem with that is screenwriters gets
tugged and they throw out their script
when they go to the next one and over
time you realize you just write a bunch
of unfinished screenplays and so ice one
day I'll just really frustrating I said
you know what I got to stop braiding
myself into these corners if I can't get
out of them and so I came up with this
kind of rule of thumb that if you write
yourself in the corner the only way you
can get out of that corner is to write
your way out you can't just throw it
away it's not an option so I started
doing that and it really helped me out a
lot my goal with this going back to the
script that I'm writing I just want to
show the friends and family you know
maybe submit to a screenplay competition
or two but hopefully the script will go
somewhere but then again it probably
won't
to be honest I mean but I always like to
think that a good unproduced screenplay
is your best sample work because you
never know what that unproduced
screenplay might lead to other great
examples of future projects you know
somebody might like your work and go oh
this is great can you write this so you
never know where that that's going to
lead I try to write every single day and
i work nine to five monday through
friday like a lot of screenwriters or
aspiring screenwriter is out there so
you have to keep in mind that you have
to make time for yourself i know a lot
of people say that but it's true whether
it's twentieths before work whether it's
during your lunch break whether it's
after work or maybe you're right a bunch
of notes on you know sticky pads and
then you wait to the weekend and you
just jam it all out on your keyboard you
know but you have to make time than
right and so I try to write wonder where
I can even if it's five ten minutes a
day it's better than not bringing
anything at all I don't really have a
story so to speak about my screenwriting
career because its work in progress and
maybe think about it in the way I
already just told you everything about
myself and what I'm working on so that's
really kind of a story in itself so yeah
that's really ill and saying keep
writing every single day